[Music]
hello everybody i'm grandmaster joel
Benjamin and I'm happy to be serving as
a grand master in residence
essentially with chess club and welcome
to my class insane in the endgame and I
think I have some pretty cool and games
for this show anybody who watched the
Karen's Cup over the last week and a
half knows that it's there's a little
something extra when you get to watch a
game in person and see it unfold and so
the first game that I'm gonna show is
particularly special because I had a
ringside seat for this one I was sitting
right next to it it was played in the
Moscow Olympiad in 1994 and the the
player of the black pieces in this game
is none other than then yasser sara Juan
who has just completed another wonderful
commentary gig here in st. Louis
so Yasha was playing board for and I was
playing board three this was our match
against Peru and with this match we
start to make comeback we scored three
and a half half but a big reason for
that was that Yassa was able to pull out
this endgame with black now just a
little background we're gonna get into
something that is really my jam because
I wrote a book called liquidation on the
chessboard and in fact this this game
appears in that book there's a new
addition just came out in 2019 with a
hundred extra pages of good stuff like
this so this is the kind of thing I've
given an awful lot of thought to in the
last few years okay so so on is is black
his opponent is named Philemon Cruz and
it's white to move in this
okay so the pawn on a three can be taken
now the question is should white take
with the the king or should white take
with the rook want to try to offer your
opinion on that one
right the the the the most important
part of the answer is if you take with
the king you have to reckon with the
possible pawn ending okay
now the thing is it's not entirely clear
just eyeballing it why the endgame why
this pawn ending is especially good for
black because both sides have their
advantages like in the coming pawn
ending white is going to have one
significant advantage yeah white is
going to have an outside pass pawn the
see pawn is an outside pass pawn and the
program is when you have an outside pass
pawn you can you know stretch the
defense make the King go after it and
then go in and get the other pawns but
black has advantages too and actually
just mention one that the black King can
can take up a good position on c5
there's also something about the King
side pawn structure that's very
important to note this pawn on g4 what
purpose is that pawn on g4 do it does
something very very important for end
games especially pawn and games any idea
it freezes those pawns right because if
the on passant
rule let's not forget that so if either
of these pawns f pawn or H pawn moves by
takes that means white has no reserve
pawn moves which is very important for a
pawn endgame now the thing is the player
playing white I I really don't know if
he thought that you know that Sarah
won't actually go into the pawn anything
or not you know maybe just thought that
King takes is entirely safe now the
thing about rook takes is if you take
with the rook black and play rook to e2
and okay there's no question the block
is gonna start taking pawns but White
has a good counter play with this C pawn
I can for instance give a check on a7
and the King has to go to the King side
to keep everything protected and why
could push c5 okay black might clean out
most of the Kings side but even then you
know that running pawn may in the end
force black to give up his rook so it
would be you know a position that's
that's at least a little bit unclear
whereas as it turns out King takes King
takes is actually a forced loss right so
black checks
okay first step is to plant the king
okay now next Black has to think about
how he wants to advance his kingside
pawns and this is not a position where
black is able to make an outside passed
pawn in the kingside in a natural way
but he can do something with with the
pawns especially the ones towards the
middle that will take away something
important from white right now white is
shuttling the King white would like to
play King C King is on c3 like to play
King d3 King c3 and wait like that while
black used up balls pawn moves but black
doesn't have to let white wait in
exactly that way he can take one of
these moves away right so how can how
can white and black limit the options
that white has for the King they can
take away the d3 Square right if we
advance the pawns in a certain way so I
believe you also played e5 now King d3
have five Kings e3 and e4
so that's I guess I could could be step
two so now the white king if it wants to
protect the pawn it's gonna have to step
over to the B file or it's getting far
away from the action okay all right well
what if white says okay I'm gonna make a
run for it King D - I'm gonna just give
up this pawn all right so the f5 is
definitely a target to attack but let's
say black comes back now if if white
does not keep going in black is is going
to be able to win this position with an
extra pawn because basically King and
pawn ending with an extra pawn just a
simple extra pawn if there's this many
pawns on the board it's it's gonna be
fairly routine so let's say white goes
King F for King e6 King g5
now there's a cool move king e5 King say
h5 all right let's say the King sits on
the G pawn to prevent f4 but it doesn't
actually prevent f4 king takes pawn f3
so in this type of position is there's
always all kinds of tactics like this -
to promote pawns okay so the white cane
would like to stay in touch with this F
pawn alright but so let's say if you
wait with the King you play something
like age 4 now black can make a queen or
get in position to make a queen with a
little tactic here alright the King is
trying to stay on the pawn but we can
force the King off the pawn right all
right h5 check em King takes pawn to e3
Queens
if King h3 you don't have to push III
yet we can we can bring King d4 and then
next move can be III and make a queen
and note that when the pawns are very
far advanced you're always winning the
race white never has any time to
contemplate trying to make a queen
himself in time okay so we can go all
the way back to this position have to e4
and so white sees he's got a he's got a
by this time so he plays King b3
that's a new main line okay so position
starting to take shape we see that white
is kind of reduced to King c3 King b3
all right so what does black want to do
well black black is gonna have to use
those Kings side pawns to somehow create
a passed pawn that white can't stop and
so to do this right what we need to do
is we need when it's go time
we want that King on b3 one as far as
far away as possible so that's why
Yasser so Yasser has to time it
correctly right so the only pawn that
can move now SH pawn if he goes two
squares white plays King back to c3 and
then black is gonna have to make a
gambit a sacrifice when the king is on
c3 so under those with that explanation
the move h6
seems a lot less mysterious and that's
important thing about endgames
pawns can move one square or two squares
and black had the option of making one
reserved tempo move with a pawn or two
so King c3 h5 King b3 alright well now
it's it's time to get going here
it's gonna black it's gonna have to to
make make a sacrifice to get things
going now should he should he play
should he play f4 or should he play h4
which one it should he sacrifice to try
to get things going
so we play h4 and white takes well
immediately becomes apparent that we we
have an issue here
all right the issue is that this H pawn
is now rolling it's actually black is
actually out of the square of it so
that's that's an immediate threat it
means that if you know black doesn't
force a queen right away that you know
it's not gonna be able to stop that so
that doesn't make sense it wouldn't make
sense is what black wants to do is black
wants to create a passed pawn on the
outside so f4 that's smooth now it's not
checkers white doesn't doesn't have to
take it's not it's legal to to pass on
it so you know what if white plays King
c3 okay well then what black would do is
push this pawn to f3 and and this
creates all almost a protected passed
pawn situation because black is getting
ready to play III and Queen the F pawn
so that means you know the bad news here
for why it is that he has to abandon the
pawn right away and you know black will
happily take it King III and then what
once you get to here I think pretty much
pretty much any way you go about this is
going to win because the F pawn is
always faster than anything so you you
could come back but you can also play
King's c3 and takes and King D 2 and
just go in and and get that F pawn and
that Queens very quickly all right so we
you're back
F for so white has to take okay
so oops what happened there all right so
my bad so white takes that's that is our
main line now and now Sarah Wong
I mean his idea is to Queen something
all the way on the edge so it might be
it might be possible to play h4 here but
he does decides to start with III just
to make sure there's no possibility the
White King can come over when black
plays III instead of taking now
now clearly he has to take it and then
h4 okay well seems like blacks plan has
been a success because now the past pawn
is unstoppable
but let's not chalk it up for black just
yet because there are consequences to
sacrificing all these pawns so white now
white starts pushing f5 well okay so
what happens if we race well Sage III
takes takes f6 okay so black is on the
sixth rank white is on a six ring so we
need to slow down if we just push white
will also Queen so King comes back but
now why it gets this very nice check
this very nice tempo and if the King
goes back to d7 White's gonna push that
ball again with tempo all right so let's
say King e6 and pushed c6 I mean the
pawns are unstoppable of course but
they're just fast enough
c7 King D 7 and well I mean the problem
is that that if if white
the Queen like Queens and then makes it
quick if white is actually fast enough
to make a queen then black could
suddenly find himself on the on the the
the short end of a queen ending and you
know play in misery for a long long time
so we go back to this vision after f5
and the thing is what Yasser has to do
is he has to slow down the white pawn he
needs to win another tempo so that he
makes a queen and his opponent does not
now getting pretty far into this thing
when you think about this is now moved
60 and that rook trade happened began
move 48 so he's already calculated
pretty far ahead but you know these
variations were kind of forcing there
weren't many branches so it's kind of
it's kind of easy to get this far and
you know for a really strong Grandmaster
this kind of thing can be done in your
head but I you know admit that for you
know a lot of people mean they may not
be able to calculate all this it might
be might have to be a little bit of
intuition to be able to to get all this
so yeah so after f5
he plays King d6 alright okay so if c5
check the black king can just take that
pawn because it's still in the square of
the F pawn and connected passed pawns
really won't help very much because you
know black King doesn't have to take
them this needs to stop them okay so it
looks at first like you know king d6
what is white gonna do I mean okay c5
teh you take f6 King e6 and you take
that so is that just the end well not
quite because white has another trick up
his sleeve he can support his past pawns
that's just it's not just I mean a black
and move his King and and try to affect
the race so can white
so white plays king before and king
before is kind of handy move because it
prepares to play c5 with check a nice
little tempo all right so let's say
black races again g3 takes takes pawn
gets to the fifth rank okay so all right
King moves now well I mean this is
basically going to come out to the same
as the last one whichever way the King
goes you push the other pawn so the King
goes to d7 you push F and now you push
see the thing is you get you get this
one with the check and that means that
you're going to Queen one of those pawns
is going to Queen so we see that after
King before we we still come up short if
we go for the full-on race so Yas it
still has work to do to to pick up a
tempo so if if the straight straight on
pushing with g3 doesn't work what can
black do instead to try to win time to
get the pawn through yes
what's it what's the difference
well it's gonna is it's gonna I mean I
don't see the difference here between
queening aji pawn or an H pawn I mean
it's it's not gonna be faster that's so
so black black has to nee has to win a
little bit of time so what what what
options does he have here this is one
way it's almost a process of elimination
there are there are so few possibilities
it's just pushing or or King move yeah
the King II 5 yeah that's what he does
and it's kind of interesting that that
spending that move to go and take the
pawn on f5 will gain time but the idea
is that the two pawns are stretching the
defense and often advancing with check
so so once the F pawn goes the the C
pawn can only get through with the help
of the King also note that it wouldn't
help to do something like efore to
protect the pawn because then when black
pushes then c5 doesn't come with check
so white is too slow okay so
so after king after king e5 all right c5
is played and takes the pawn okay so now
that that the C point the king is still
in range of the of the C of the C pawn
all right
actually I know now that I checked my
notes I realized that that that after
the move kingi five okay just before we
took this pawn white actually resigned
in that position showing that he saw
exactly where where
Yaser was going but so so then these
moves weren't actually played but let's
let's see how this could have gone okay
all right y can play c6 and black has to
come back but it's still not done
because the king can can come and help
all right so let's say the King comes
and helps King d5 all right
so white white already has the pawn in
the sixth rank so it's still not
entirely clear that black is faster
because black can put upon the six rank
White's gonna move the King but I put
spawn seventh rank white puts upon the
seventh rank alright so how does it how
does he also work out the win
if it was just the C policy monitors to
the black King you could force the
kingdom out of the way by Suzy Wong but
if the King got to see a I'm just I'm
just saying but if the if the Kings on
c8 there's no well that's for sure but
can you really get the King to c8 I
don't see how that's gonna happen
because white is gonna move the King
first White's next move
really in any case okay if you play g3
I'll take it first but White's next move
is going to be King be six so if black
tries to play King e7 King be six King
t8 we don't get there in fact now now we
lose because we we actually lost a lot
of time there so in this position after
King b5 we need a better plan than that
okay I mean that's that kind of thing is
often a solution to endgame problems but
do you see what do you see why it makes
a difference to have that that pawn on
the h-file oh if you it's okay if you
don't we'll see it soon enough
right right because so how does let's
see how does this how does this make a
difference all right white plays King b6
well because what does white have to do
to make a Queen c7 we don't have to let
that Queen right King d7 and now check
h1 to check and then you bring the Queen
over or check and you take the pawn on
c7 so really an amazing endgame and
let's see so that that's that comes out
to move 68 so basically basically was a
around 20 moves deep from the moment
that that black made the check to go
into the pawn ending so there was a lot
of calculation involved and I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna say that that that
that deep a calculation is so easy for
for people to make sometimes but this
but there is a lot of sort of general
stuff in there too you know like the
idea of of you know how you can how you
can hold up pawns you know the idea that
if you if you can somehow bring it down
to just the just the one pawn queen
against you rather than the two separate
pawns and also of course the idea that
when you have that two on one like that
you have the option of which file you
want to Queen on so you could Queen on
the normally you just take and Queen
them the G file but in that key last
variation you Queen on the H file
because you get there with check and
it's really you can imagine like to be a
to be actually sitting next to this game
and watching this this unfold you know
it was like you know hard to keep my jaw
from from
from dropping open you know because was
just you know pretty amazing so alright
so next I want to show you another
ending and this this is actually not
from my not from my book because it was
played to wait to get in there but what
I like about this game is that this is
not a grandmaster game and you're not
going to find this on the database
because this this was played by by two
elementary school kids and it's not only
the grandmasters that get end games
everybody gets them and everybody has to
play them
now it's scholastic chess it's a fast
time control game let's say we've got to
put the White King and Don I will not
let me make it legal without a White
King all right
Player of the black pieces is is a as a
kid that that plays for school that I I
do coaching for the student Columbia
grammar in New York City so so that's
why I saw the game because he brought it
back to the team room and he was ok
about 1800 and his opponent the young
lady had I'm not familiar with that she
was rated about about 1600 I think so
it's it's black is Danny white is Mary
so Mary against Danny all right so all
right we start in a position where white
is in check so immediately it's it's a
fundamental decision and again should
white go into the the pawn ending or
should white move the King now it's
actually possible to play King c1 it's
not it's not an automatic rejection
because the b-pawn is actually quite
strong if you take the pawn in f2 I
don't I don't see how you're going to
stop that pawn you know especially you
try to try to give checks I I still have
you know this idea of of rook c2 and not
able to get back so you can't take the
pawn in f2 but black has a pretty good
move here in d3 King D 3 and if B 6 you
can check really to kind of open things
up for the King and then just retreat
the right back and you know it took pass
a position but then the King is ready to
run in and maybe an advantage for black
okay so the thing is
all right so white plays rook c2 and I
have to say that you know being in the
Scholastic business for about 20 years
now
and having observed many many games I
find that the that the trade into the
pawn ending is irresistible for most
young players I think that that comes
because you know when they start out and
they're losing games they they try to
draw by getting a stalemate so they you
like to be down to their King for
whatever reason so black has a big
decision here and I would like to say
that I would have been happier if my my
my students here had taken more time on
this decision I think he played he he
played it pretty quickly but he he went
for the trade and and it's it's it's
kind of a similar ending because the
King goes back so we have another
situation with with with an outside past
pawn but also black has not only has a
king side majority but it's very
important that the pawns are far
advanced because that means that black
is able to win a lot of races you know
that that if it comes down to that kind
of that little mass pawns in the center
versus any other pawns that black will
get will Queen quickly and and that's
good we'll see how that that plays out
in some variations
okay so white plays King c3 alright so
this is this is a very interesting
moment because now we're going to see an
example of accidental genius because
here Danny plays the the absolute best
move but for all the wrong reasons
he plays the move
g4 and he played it basically because he
just didn't want to take the pawn
because then why it would play King to
to d4
but of course black is is able to a
white is able to force the black King
away anyway so so he played g4 this is
so I think well we kind of start with
how the game went and then we'll we'll
see how it could have been played better
g4 b6 King takes b6 King Defour and now
keep in mind that these end games are so
complicated so tricky that you really
have to think very deeply and and work
out yes well in fact it's lost four it's
lost four black after h4 and h4 is
exactly what he did and you want to do
the same thing you're playing for a
trick but the problem is that white
actually saw the trick coming all right
your trick is that you want after king
e5 you want to play g3 another
breakthrough sacrifice and the e pawn
Queens but what's the problem with this
reasoning no no no it's it's actually
quite simple you take this way you just
take back and that that clears the way
for the e pawns come to come through
h4 h4 is a losing move ok h4 it's a it's
a kind of a transparent trap you know
and if you're you know if you're 1800
and you're playing something a little
bit lower rated you can think like yeah
okay I'm gonna trick my opponent but you
I did not fall for the trick
why did not fall fall for the trick and
played g3 and in fact now the position
is is lost for black because white will
start scooping up pawns and okay you
could play h3 but then white is just
taking pawns faster so so he took takes
king b5 King e5 King c4 okay so my
question is how does white win this
position
well I think you're getting ahead of
things okay you have to get into a
situation where you're you're in
position to to promote the point what's
what's gonna be the next couple of moves
okay so if you take an f5 my Kings gonna
come into d3 are you thinking that one
over now ah see these these these things
can't be rushed and I you know I didn't
see it I mean you you really can the
same problem of this class is just you
can't actually really watch these games
being played because they keep all the
adults out of the room you know because
people people go crazy what happened is
that ye just took the pawn and I think
that she was probably just happy to draw
again it's that I think it's a little
bit that syndrome when you play a higher
rated player is this something that
people really have to work on to not not
settle you know think oh not settle for
Less in any position you should always
want to win and draw if you can't win so
the game ended kingi to hang out for
king takes now the e pawn is too fast
the White has to take take King only
draw but we go back to this position if
white plays King f4 it's a big time the
Suk's long because King e2 King takes
King takes king f4 and then as you said
they do you Queen the cheap on that is
that is how the game ends but White has
Twite has to do this little dance with
the King and button black doesn't have
anything he that he can do because if
you go King if you keep your epon
protected and then white will take the
cheap one and come back and win easily
so this that's the thing is that that's
why I say accidental genius because
because he played it with a terrible
idea
h4 was was
well I mean it's not terrible to have
the idea but it was terrible to play it
without working out why it might not
work and he just I think he kind of
blitzed it off and it ended up but it
should have cost him a whole point and
the game ended in a draw now the thing
is that yeah g4 was actually a strong
move and h4 is where he goes wrong and
the fact of the matter is what black is
is winning this position okay if it's
not playing h4 he's gotta move his king
right okay so where should he move his
king that actually is correct but why is
king c6 better than king b5
not really ya know it's still the same
problem why it's always white always has
g3 the h4 is not part in that part of
the solution at all
the thing is king c6 is strong because
because it forces it forces king e5
because because black is getting ready
to play king d6 and then the white king
doesn't doesn't get in at all
so king c6 forces king e5 and now you
you start running in and that's the
amazing thing is that it actually does
not matter whether the black king is on
d4 or d3 the fact that that a pawn is so
far advanced is going to to put block on
top because white has no time to go
after the h5 pawn that's why it's got to
be an H 5 not h4 because then g4 drops
so why can't go after that pawn if you
if if she plays King g5 King D 3 King
takes pawn King e2 now white is white is
taking pawns faster but black is
queening faster and this this there
isn't any way to really help with
anything here because I mean you can
play you play you can play king f4 it
doesn't help black is gonna go king d3
and King you to you can't wait g3 it
doesn't really help to play g3
okay you can try for a trick but of
course black weights and now black
Queens of Jeep on so that is so it's a
very funny very funny position we go
back to that to that key moment here
that that King King c6 wins
h4 as played should have lost but let's
go back to this g4 move the act the
accidental genius okay
why is g4 brilliant well what's really
amazing here is that g4 is the only
winning move because if black takes on
b5
why it can draw this position
it's it's just amazing what move white
play this is I don't know if anybody
beyond computer is going to find this I
mean maybe Grand Master having some time
in his clock okay so it's not King g4
you know but so what king d4 back and
play chief for again right so what move
should white play then if if the pawn
not being on g4 is it's really important
yes know that even seems you know seems
a little plausible h4 and thought about
that so I don't want to dismiss it too
quickly but I think I think the problem
is that black will probably take it King
King King yeah I think the problem is
that black is just running in again
but now there now there are more black
pawns so it's kind of hard to take them
and again the same thing you have to
hang around the e pawn so even even
though it seems like you're faster
because you have to you can't allow bike
to win f2 and Queen you actually have to
lose time and then black is gonna it's a
rook pawn but still the white king is
not it's not on h1 so yeah so h4 doesn't
work but the I mean okay if H 4 is the
outlandish move that doesn't work it's
g4 cheap for yeah g4 g4 is the drawing
move okay so if f g4 King d4 and then
basically just you just go over and and
and clean everything out so HG King
g-forces that's the amazing thing is
that it just it just kills
the the the flexibility of the of the of
the black structure by with that g4 most
so okay let's see what could happen
let's say King before king e5 King c4
takes King d3 okay well I've already
told you that white can draw this
position I think this I think there are
this more than one way to do it okay but
we have to find at least one way so how
how can white draw this position okay
you play King g5 make yourself happy I'm
gonna play King II - yeah that's that's
the key is that that a pawn is that's
public enemy number one we have to get
rid of that so we have to we have to
touch the e pawn and when black takes F
- King takes e4 but attacks H - white
attacks g4 and we get down to King's
again I think that it is also possible
to draw by taking on g4 but it's it's
it's less direct King e -
and now what
but the problem is that you made your
moves and you made my moves too and I
would make different moves so if you
play King g3 I will play a different
move I will not play g4 all right so you
play King g3 what move why play
King f1 this is the problem King f1
okay so again King can't move because
King you have to Queens f3 allows III f4
allows III also black is too fast
queening with check what about h3
yeah you crawl along the back and six
long that e-pawn is gonna Queen
so King g3 can you play f4 in in this
position know which position f4 okay
I play III do you want to play King f3
but thing is black is still too fast
I'll I'm just gonna take on f4 yeah okay
if you play King EE to king g2 and the F
pawn Queens or h4 King f1 and the the e
pawn Queens white doesn't doesn't get
get far enough so King g3 doesn't work
but actually this is still a draw yes
yes King f5 alright so you get you you
gotta get rid of a pawn first so if I
take you take the e pawn and you're
gonna attack my Jeep on next move but
okay I'm gonna try try to be a little
bit trickier you pie king f5 Olympic
King f3
actually they may be again more than one
way but I think one way is a little
simple yes yeah this is this is what I'm
thinking but I think that king e5 is is
good enough here but III think I would
prefer h3 just because it gives black
fewer options I mean black is really
forced to take now now you take efore
and next move next move King f5 and and
you know that's that's going to do it so
so that she said g4 is is a drawing move
and we saw that in the game after after
after g4 b6 takes King g4 so we know H
for losers
we know king c6 wins but why doesn't
king b5 win
we've kind of hinted at what the reason
is
but what does white play to make a draw
here
well we see we saw that if king e5 the
black king comes in once the King comes
to the C file then it's it's gonna keep
going so you can't hold it off but can
white do something on the King side to
help the answer is yes he can and that
move is h3 well let's see what can what
can black do well really I think black I
mean it's a funny thing I think that
that blacks winning chances really
evaporate right away after that move hmm
because if you try the same kind of
strategy by playing aged hg now if FG
king takes e4 and the white king has
time to come over but now now the thing
is when you now when you take f5 you're
going to be able to to to get to that
pawn quicker and you know you again
you're keeping the King farther away at
g3 g3 is never going to be enough to win
because white you know white can can
always with sorry hg for white to move
okay so so if King e5 if King e5 there's
g3 but now I can play g3 because the
black yes ken white also play f3 in this
position No
f 3 it's a good question that's why I
love I love doing these these positions
for four classes because something new
always comes up I think I think that's
the first time anyone asked that how
does black win after f3
I'm used to these themes I can see them
very quickly
I'll give you the first move this one
well it's you know it's process of
elimination
g3 okay now we throwing the Queen so I
have to run back f4 yeah once you get to
there then the king is just gonna creep
around and take the take the f3 pawn so
f3 it's just not it's not quite in time
but I do believe that g3 is good enough
because the king is just too far away
now this tempo matters remember we we
were looking at this position with the H
pawns on the board and the big
difference was that white could could
did not have time to get to h5 but he
does have time to get to g4 and and
actually actually now what we've we've
actually factually transposed into what
happened in the game yeah this is
actually what happened in the game so
after after h3 well after h3 basically
there's a lot of different ways that
that black can make a draw but there
aren't any ways he can win like for
instance he can take on h3 and h4 king
e5 King c4
King takes King d3 alright now we have
to we have to stay in touch with the e
pawn familiar theme King ee - King takes
King takes and what happens what's the
how does this game end
King D for D as in David going that way
okay it's King F for and then and then
what happens no I like to trick people
King you to drawers I mean it's what is
that the kind of thing where a lot of
people sometimes in their in their
analysis they they sort of force these
moves the moves that are natural to play
like going after the pawn but King G to
has no point because of King G for and
then then white actually wins but you'd
but now you you just come back and
because it's an it's an H pawn and my
soon-to-be familiar joke that Apple has
not invented the I file so the king the
King can't go on there's no King I five
that would be winning
so it's you know King at five kf5 and
just you just follow the king and and
and it's draw so I think I think that
I've burned through every variation
there so I mean it's it's it's really
it's really kind of an amazing amazingly
rich endgame and the the little analysis
that we had in the team room after the
game only only scratched the surface you
know in fact I am i first thought was
that that that that Danny Danny marrow
had gone into that endgame only to lose
it that he should have lost it but
actually when I thought about it later I
thought like yeah you know maybe maybe
it's not so bad maybe it's a draw and
then then I started started looking at
it on the engine and I realized it's
actually a win with with best play but
it's it's amazing that that position on
move on move 44 this key position
h4 has played losses King b5 draws King
c6 wins
that's pretty stark you know this is
like three candidate moves and they all
lead with best play they all lead to
different results yes yes yes and and
and we got to that point before King c6
is is it's forcing White's hand with the
King because because if the thing is
that if you try something like h3 King
d6
I would imagine King g6 but maybe could
also mmm should block take well I'm not
sure but III think that this this kind
of position is usually winning fairly
routinely although with 4 and 3 it's a
little it's a little simpler P hmm let
me think about this one because I'm
seeing some drawing variations like King
III King e5 g 3 f4 check GF 4 king f5
and now what happens
you need to came back to the last string
the idea is
huh well maybe maybe it's possible that
there's more than one way to I don't
think so I I think white needs to buy
candy to you know not mess around yeah
King takes and get this position with
black to move and then III what happens
on III I think why can't actually take
it maybe could move the King as well
that I count this right I was never very
good at math it looks like I counted to
that right now you said bring the King
back to the first rank so King e1 or
yeah I gotta be you can't let that you
can't let the black King get to get to
oh sorry I have to what I have to do is
I have to you have to do this there's
this but well maybe that's maybe that's
a draw also gonna go III
win or draw
yeah kingi - because you know you don't
want to give him king position he takes
you take okay got opposition King f3
King f1 looks like a draw so yeah so I
was sort of going against what I was
saying before but uh but maybe h3 maybe
the the solution is that you take it and
play King g6 because because now number
one year potential for the King to come
in to have four but you also have
potential to push f4 so I think this
position is it's looking oh I think
we're gonna go to one it we're gonna get
to one of my favorite positions we're
gonna I think I I think yeah I think
we're gonna wrap this up with one of my
favorite positions okay so let's say
white plays well actually I'm not
yeah let's say white plays f3 let's say
white plays after he takes King III now
this ending of F and H against H pawn
it's very complicated and I admit that
when I started to write the book I did
not understand it but you know after
studying it I see there are rules to it
okay so one basic rule is that if the
defenders pawn is not on h2 if it's
moved it's always lost yes
well black could play h4 but but really
doesn't have to because white because
playing age for for white will never
help that will never help that would
just guarantee that black will be able
to go and take the pawn so you can
really do that anytime actually you're
going to make it easier by saving that
f4 like if h4 King f5 immediately wins
so okay you can decide what you want to
do with the King so this position is
winning with either side to move if h4
King g4 zukes long and then you take h4
if it's blacks move you win with King f4
King goes back then King g3 and then
then you can take the pawn in h4 but the
thing is let's say let's say we miss
play this let's say let's try to miss
play this slightly how can we do this
let's say we do let's say we do King e1
and then we go
h4 and then we go King f1 and King at 4
and then King f2 okay this this is a
classic position I know of many examples
where this this was reached in
tournament play and the players agreed
to a draw but in fact it's it's a
fundamental win kingi for yeah ok now
where do I go if I go the basic rule of
thumb is that you go straight back right
if I go if I go to e 1 then then you're
gonna then you're gonna Queen the pawn
or you're gonna you're going to
something the pawn you're not
necessarily gonna Queen it you're maybe
you're gonna rook it or maybe you play
King f3 and make me a queen is Queen
Queen right away this tell me ok so that
means I have to go straight back
and this is where the the great Viktor
Korchnoi would would make his comment to
me from a similar type position yes and
it would be knowing something about
triangles because if King F - King F 4
is Oogie and if King F 1 all right then
we don't want to you don't want to go to
F or cousin King F 2 we're back we're
back in it but if we go kingi for this
is a position that white cannot be on
move because they got to either put King
e1 and then King III wins or King F -
King F 4 at black and penetrated to G 3
that that's what that's one of the
things that I that I learned in writing
in writing this book I mean this this
classic thematic endgame I mean it
didn't look like we were gonna get to it
from from the position we had but it
pops up in some lines and you never know
when it will pop up but just the
knowledge that you know like it's like
geometry it's like a theorem okay if
that pawn if the defenders pawn is done
in h2 it's always lost okay if the if
the stronger side has the H pawn on its
original square it's always lost and I
learned I learned that the hard way I
had a game against Hikaru Nakamura and
this this was in the book I was a
grandmaster well I think well he was a
grandmaster - by then but he was I mean
he might have I think he still was in
his teens you know and we had a queen
ending and well naka was famous for
moving very quickly but he pretty
quickly played a queen move to force a
trade of Queens and give up one of his
pawns to go into the rook pawn
at bishop pawn against rook pawn ending
and he just splits off all the moves
because he do that you just push your
bishop on all the way and in the end you
win because you have a choice of moving
your rook pawn one square or two squares
so the other side is always in Cid's one
so there are these are these kind of
theorem there are these rules to these
fundamental end games if you know the
rules to the fundamental end games that
can really help they pop up in in these
more complicated and you got to take one
more question and then we'll wrap up
[Music]